he's the Commissioner of the NBA Adam
Silver how are you Adam hey rich I'm
great thanks for having oh thanks for
coming on our are you ecstatic of all
this news all the all the drama that's
being played out in all these rosters
and free free agency and front office's
okay yeah I love the interest I'm not
ecstatic about the drama I mean I feel
bad for what's ever going on in
Cleveland and I have no first-hand
information but I assume where there's
smoke there's fire and Brian Wynn horses
sort of has been cataloging LeBrons
career for a long time and he usually
has very you know accurate insights from
that team so I you know it's upsetting
to hear that when you see superstar
players to who have coexisted who had so
much success together obviously three
finals in a row you know one
championship to hear that for whatever
reason there's a sense that they can't
continue to coexist I mean yeah that's
drama but it's not necessarily the kind
of drama those little bit the league
wants well I guess look on the bright
side Commissioner neither am I going to
join the Warriors right right you never
know that's right about that said it
does seem that a lot of this activity
all has been undertaken by a bunch of
teams that's seeing what the Warriors
did need to mean gal Mori called in an
arms race is what he called it right now
do you think that that even though the
super team that mentality that I know
that you and some others lamented on
occasion last year has brought this into
being well yes and and that's the
positive side of it which is as I said
during the finals we should be
celebrating excellence and we have some
of the greatest athletes in the world in
our league some of the greatest
competitors in the league and and some
of the great greatest team presidents
and owners and none of them want to
stand still and so the reaction to the
Warriors was never going to be well
let's just stand back and watch them win
year after year it's we're going to
retool and how is it we can compete
against them and maybe even how can we
emulate some of the things they've done
I mean I I have to say I mean I accept
the term
superteam in a certain context but at
least historically super teams were not
teams that were built through the draft
and if you look at the Warriors yes of
course they added an incredible free
agent in Durant and that he's more than
a footnote or an asterisk but you begin
with the 7th pick and Steph the 11th
pick and play the 35th pick and draymond
Green bringing Andre Iguodala onto the
team Steve Kerr you know you know
incredible management of that team so I
I just feel like it's it's that's what
should be emulated by other teams in
this league by drafting well building
teams with with incredible cultures look
no further than Cleveland it's not just
a function of aggregating great players
then you got to get those players to
want to be on the same page to sacrifice
for each other you know and to be able
to coexist over a long period of time
and over if you look back at the history
of this league meant there have been
many attempts to put together great
players that have been that have broken
up on their own just because those great
players weren't able to co-exist and be
a commissioner out of silver joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show - what do
you and your colleagues in the front
office attribute the bursts in ratings
and popularity of the summer league that
we just saw to me it was an extension of
the enormous interest coming off of our
season and plus what appears to be a
really exciting traffic and and because
the Las Vegas market is so close to Los
Angeles you've always had a lot of
Lakers and Clippers fans out in that
part of the country and I think the fact
that there's been so much interest in in
the entire ball family but of course in
Lonzo in particular and on top of that
he had great summer league he was our
MVP of the summer league and you had a
lot of Laker fans there as well but I
you know at the same time we've seen
growth virtually every year in the
summer league we've had better coverage
it's as part of our new television deal
with ESPN we had something like 46 games
on one ESPN outlet or another and then
the rest of the games are on NBA TV plus
you could get them on various apps and
through other digital media so I think
the exposure
as well made a big difference and I
think Las Vegas since we started playing
our summer league there 15 years ago or
so has become much more of a destination
for major league sports you know I joked
when I was out there with Carolyn
Goodman that the Mayor of Las Vegas that
the NBA should be getting a commission
because she said what are you bringing a
team I said bringing a team I said since
we start our summer league and held an
all-star game in Vegas you now have the
NFL coming to town the NHL coming to
town and it really is my feeling that we
own the first two weeks of July on the
sports calendar in Las Vegas we're very
much a fixture in the community and on
top of that because there's so much
interest in our summer league we use it
to have an owners meeting slide all the
all the owners encounter at the Wynn
Hotel where we had meetings and then we
brought in our team executives sort of
our equivalent of baseball winter
meetings take place in Las Vegas in the
summer we had 1500 team executives there
for four days four of meetings as well
so we're a big part of Las Vegas in the
summer and I think that generates even
additional interest in our summer league
well in terms of that I'd like to
revisit what you may have discussed with
your owners and the Board of Governors
in those meetings recently in a couple
minutes but while we were on the subject
of Vegas I know you've been vocal you've
written up at an op-ed piece in The New
York Times called legalize and regulate
regulate sports betting you were on a
panel at the Paley Center in New York
City recently with commissioners of the
three other major North American sports
including my boss in the NFL and you are
just I mean you're putting it out there
Commissioner like hey people are
gambling we might as well just realize
that regulated how can the NBA embrace
sports betting and make sure that it
doesn't metastasize into the into the
final product in the same way that we
all know that the referee Tim Donaghy
did Commissioner well let me begin by
saying both there's an enormous legal
sports betting industry right now
outside of the United States where we
are a fairly popular sport in Europe and
and certainly in Asia and people in
those markets can legally bet on the NBA
right now and we get access to the data
we know if there's aberrational behavior
we know is that there
is unpredictable interest or action on
particular games and we can then
investigate to try to avoid the Tim
Donaghey type situation you referenced
which is where we had a referee who
never never demonstrated that he was
altering the outcome of games but was
clearly betting on games that he and
other officials were involved in I would
then say in terms of the United States
number one reason for having more
transparency is precisely to detect
aberrant behavior that it when you have
a transparent market like the New York
Stock Exchange if there's insider
trading for example all kinds of Flags
go off in the stock exchange computers
because they have highly sophisticated
algorithms knowing that there's an
unusual trading pattern and so therefore
it doesn't necessarily mean that there's
insider trading but it gives them reason
to investigate and if you talk to the
European soccer clubs right now that's
the same thing they do with all the
betting exchanges if there's any odd
behavior then they investigate Morphin
you know they either find there's a
problem or not right now in the back to
the United States it's been estimated
that it's up to a four hundred billion
dollar illegal industry of sports
betting in the US alone right now
there's almost no transparency because
it's all illegal and so when in order to
catch someone who's doing something
illegal back to that Tim Donaghy case he
was caught up in in a sting an
investigation and a completely unrelated
case but he his voice appeared on a
wiretap and that's how altum Utley the
FBI caught him because there's no
there's no other means of tracking how
someone's betting on a sporting event
and it's our feeling here that it's
going on already on a widespread basis
let's make it transparent let's regulate
it and we get it what comes with
regulation is government oversight that
doesn't currently exist both on a
federal and state level in the same way
there's oversight of casinos now and and
by the way I want to be clear I
recognize there's a possibility that you
could have you know deviants who who bet
over their head and and
and you know get caught up in an
addictive way in gambling I think that's
one of the things that through a
transparent system you can monitor for
because people have to identify
themselves almost all that betting comes
through credit cards once again you can
see there's unusual behavior and and you
can also put in place programs to deal
with problem gamblers as well so I I
would just say that it's it's it's not a
perfect solution but I think by
regulating this kind of activity you
have a lot better chance of dealing with
problems than just allowing it to exist
underground in an explosive way the way
we do now and when you posited this
theory at the Paley Center did
Commissioner Goodell afterwards take you
suds and what he talked about Adam or is
there something that you think there's
might be there there with other leagues
well I would say I would never speak for
Commissioner Goodell I'm sure he's very
smart guy he's aware of the amount of
interest in his sport based on sports
betting he sees both the legal action of
course that now takes place in Las Vegas
and I'm sure he has privy to the same
studies that I do on the amount of
illegal betting and I know it's
something that he's told me in the past
that the league is continuing to study
but he certainly his position right now
is to be against it so again I won't
speak for him I will say that Rob
Manfred the Commissioner of Major League
Baseball well he hasn't come out and
said he's necessarily in favor of
legalized sports betting yet or I don't
think he has I know he's found a
position on the spectrum for closer to
me than where Roger is right now which
is I think he's recognizing that there
it may be time for a change in the law
and it's something that he and I have
had many discussions about I know there
are other people his organization have
continued to look at it and I think my
sense from Rob Manfred is that you know
he's he's more open to looking at at
what a legalized betting structure would
look like in the US couple of more
minutes with the Commissioner of the NBA
Adam silver here on the Rich Eisen show
the conversations you've had with owners
Board of Governors over the issue of
star players resting just flat-out not
suiting up just to make sure that they
get some rest during the regular season
certainly on the road
when they make their one city appearance
for the year LeBron James for clipper
fans out here in Los Angeles for them to
show up and see him in warm-ups was
particularly hurtful what where are you
on this subject with owners and coaches
and making sure this doesn't happen for
fans across the country come on you know
where we are you know which you never
used to call me commissioner what's this
welcome I can just be Adam okay I don't
know I mean you know okay at like I said
when you get the serious question
Commissioner I don't know you know I try
um paying respects man I'm on your
threats all right
you know all right mr. Eisen so that
we're our owners are is we all agree
that first of all you know what the way
you described it in the question it
makes it seem like guys just want to
rest what's what's really happening is
this is team directed resting this is
you know we're taking advantage of
modern science and technology they're
carefully tracking how much these
players sleep how the amount of movement
on the floor how tired they are oxygen
level of their blood and all that stuff
and they're making decisions to try to
avoid injury so the players can stay
healthy longer into the season be
available for playoffs and finals etc so
I ever want to leave somebody with the
sense of players you know sometimes I
hear this notion from players from the
old days we were just tougher and oh
yeah so player I heard you know you know
you if you watch if you're in the locker
room the players want to play there
aren't players raising their hand saying
I'd rather just sit on the bench and
watch you know my teammates run up and
down the floor that that's not the case
at all this is very tactical it's very
strategic but having said that because
it is tactical and strategic what we've
gone back and said to our owners and our
GM's and our coaches is we recognize a
certain amount of rest is appropriate
but to extent you're going to rest
players number one whenever possible
rest them at home to avoid the precise
asyou just raise the one time that the
East Coast the Eastern Conference team
is is in LA where that those fans have
that one chance to see that player and
then the other thing we've said is to
extent possible avoid resting multiple
starters at the same time especially
during you know
marquee national television games and
what did the owners say to that what did
the owner and the owner said we agree
and by the way and the coaches said we
agree and the GM said we agree now in
practice I know they're going to be
times when it's you know it as you know
from being around this league a long
time from being around the NFL for a
long time players are constantly banged
up and the one thing I'm trying to avoid
is getting into a position where our
teams where it's League doctor's note
versus team doctors note that you know I
think at the end there's got to be a
certain amount of good faith here as to
when a player is genuinely injured or
when a player is you know being arrested
for tactical purposes because players as
you know just walk in a locker room
after one hour games it's them you know
they're sitting in ice buckets every
portion of their body has either a heat
pad or an ice pad on them so it's again
these these guys they're tough guys it's
just really a question of how can we
keep them healthy longer throughout the
season okay so do i Adam Commissioner
Sylvie Silva's that is I don't know that
you don't know that's a little bit above
that's a little too informal that's what
you ever have you had a conversation
with a bar ball you ever have a
one-on-one chat with him um we said
hello to each other at a draft I
wouldn't say it was a full-out
conversation I mean but we had there was
a luncheon with the players and their
families and we spoke for a few minutes
I mean I you know I just congratulate
him graduated him on the fact that his
son was about to be a topic in the draft
and all the things that they've
accomplished seemed like a very nice man
okay because you're you're a big baller
in your own right and now man I went
I've gone from Commissioner to being up
see now I'm going the other way
I got a modular gotta modulate my wife
Susie wanted me to say hello so I will
die see nap now all the listeners know
we have this personal relationship like
suit Susie says hi commissioner
I love chat whether you take care we'll
chat soon
okay you got her thanks for joining
that's Adam still the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience
if you like that download our app please
just if it's a memory thing just delete
other apps you don't need those apps
this app the rich eyes and show up you
need that